julia cavaretta's phone had been acting
strangely she relives the moment she
realized for sure that it was bugged
well i was driving and i remember that i
got the first email and
but that moment we
we were confirmed that pegasus was
targeting
pegasus the spying software only sold to
governments julia was one of 22 staffers
at the news site el faro who had their
phones repeatedly infected according to
the university of toronto's citizen lab
she says many of the attacks came as
alfaro published exposes on the
government of el salvador headed by
president naib bukheli what can they
pull out of it during an attack
everything they can see for example
what the message that you are typing or
they can get access to your contacts to
your uh images your videos
it's like to having a unlock cell phone
in your hand
the journalists at el faro weren't the
only ones other media outlets and civil
rights figures were bugged too says
citizen lab
including transparency lawyer jose
marinero i think this is also a sign of
the times a sign of this government this
is a government which is intolerant to
critics is intolerant to
public scrutiny is intolerant to
accountability
and
while there's still no
no hard evidence that the the spying
came from the government everything
seems to point to the doorsteps of
the salvadorian government
which strongly denies the phone bugging
but there have been worrying signs that
the president doesn't have democracy at
the top of his agenda say critics
starting from 2020 when he marched
soldiers into congress a shock for a
country which only escaped civil war 30
years ago
the president in turn has accused
independent media outlets like el faro
of lying and attacking his government
in 2020 he announced the outlet was
under investigation for money laundering
in el salvador many people are on his
side his approval ratings are in the
80s in the working-class barrio of san
luis 3 karla vazquez pats out the day's
tortillas and tells us why
he's helped more than the other
governments for them it was only in the
campaign only then they remembered our
neighborhood but with him no he hasn't
forgotten us he always remembers us the
poorest
the neighborhood's less dangerous under
buchelli there's been cash to help them
through the pandemic even laptops for
her boys to be able to keep studying
she dismisses the media exposes as fake
news and montages like many others she
believes the president
just walking around this neighborhood
san luis three you understand why
president buchelli is so overwhelmingly
popular with the majority of salvadorans
he's given the money he's given them
food he's even given them computers for
their children during the pandemic and
what all that means to them is that he's
someone that's concerned about them the
poorest salvadorans in a way that other
presidents haven't been
bulkheli promises these people he will
take care of them
will he do the same for the country's
journalists lawyers activists
all those who are critical of him
in el salvador that's the burning
question
john holman al jazeera